[Music]
my wife is being made right now so much
[Music]
hi everyone I am Emma Bunton from the
Spice Girls and I'm here to freak out
some fans
[Music]
I was and I am and I will remain a
gigantic Spice Girls fan my whole entire
life
it's like mainly the reason I feel like
a confident woman in my life I actually
live my life according to like the
philosophy of the spice I had a Spice
Girls themed birthday party where I only
invited enough people to fill out the
Spice Girls and they were just like the
first girls I could like identify with
as adolescents / tween had all the dolls
I had all the little like fan books I
had like a spice world movie thing I had
the Polaroid camera I had that posters
on my wall and then delayed Ellen's
routines the Spice Girls were legit my
life if I could say one thing to the
Spice Girls it would be honestly this is
gonna sound so cheesy but it would be
thank you thank you so much for existing
thank you for making me a powerful
empowered woman you're a huge part of my
childhood
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god oh my god oh my god like I'm
really gonna cry I just can't even
believe that I'm literally sitting there
right now the Spice Girls mean
everything to me and continue to mean
everything to me and I really think that
you guys formed a whole entire
generation of women who believed in
themselves because you existed can I
really just say like thank you though
like I uh I don't want to cry but
whatever I was a young kid kid it was
like a thing of like Oh like I'm
different and then I would read about
you guys and what you guys went through
and I was like you know I'm gonna be
gained I'm gonna own it and it was like
girl power and it was like a power and
Latino power I'm like I can with my next
to you right now alone I feel like the
Spice Girls is why I was running around
at 10 years old screaming girl power
what did that feel like to know that you
like influence like this era it was an
incredible time but it was amazing to
watch other women support us in the way
that you know and girls and as you did
it was just so nice to have that support
and fans and people that believed in
what we were doing and we just felt like
we have a message we had great music you
know just writing our own songs just
really important to us because we wanted
for you guys to identify with whatever
we wrote we feel like we always want to
thank our fans oh my god with us oh my
god
I've so many questions for you do you
ever use big rooms anymore like I'm
stepping for the name up phone take on
those are pretty big they're not quite
as big okay why when I break my ankle a
key time something did you really yeah I
actually did did you guys do it but
girls underneath managers stuff is that
real we did some violet I love it what's
your favorite Spice Girls side yeah I'm
one's my favorite I think violet yeah
you'd be there as well but yeah yeah
that's the best I'm so grateful for this
experience you don't even know I'm shaky
I spoke to Jerry this morning and I said
the icing mr. Shue's all right guys so
much Bob we just go to the camera and do
a girl power
go Power Girl Power Girl
what a damn Monday and the biggest
thought I ever gotten to my dad with was
whether the Spice Girls or the Beatles
would go down in history as the biggest
group of all time so very dedicated I
wish I can't I'm gonna have heart attack
this the video go viral gonna be a Spice
Girl killed me